يمكنك القيام بها كل يوم
ويقول الباحثون إنهم يحتفظون
بمشاكل صحية في Bay ، فهذه بعض
الأنشطة التي ليست ممتعة فحسب ، بل إنها
مفيدة وكذلك التطوع ، إنها
أكثر من مجرد شعور جيد تحصل عليه
من مساعدة الآخرين وفقًا
لمجلة أمريكية للصحة العامة  دراسة أن
الأشخاص الذين يتطوعون يتمتعون
بحماية أفضل من الإجهاد ، ووجد الباحثون
أن أولئك الذين لا يتقاضون رواتبهم
أكثر عرضة لخطر الموت بنسبة 30 في المائة
بعد تعرضهم لحدث مرهق في الحياة ،
أظهرت دراسات الطهي في معظم الأحيان أن
الوجبة المطبوخة في المنزل أكثر صحة من وجبة واحدة.
قد تحتوي وجبات الطعام خارج المطعم على
الكثير من الزبدة والملح والزيت ، وجدت دراسة أجريت
عام 2014 في مجلة Public Health Nutrition
أن الأشخاص الذين يأكلون بانتظام في المنزل
يستهلكون حوالي 130 سعرًا حراريًا أقل من
أولئك الذين لا يفعلون ذلك ويلعبون مع
حيواناتك الأليفة وفقًا لمراكز
لقد ثبت أن السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها تقلل رعاية الحيوان من
ضغط الدم ومستويات الكوليسترول
وتزيل الشعور بالوحدة
والعزلة.  قبعة فوق كل السعرات الحرارية التي
تحرقها في الحال أو فيدو للنزهة
في دقيقة الصحة اليوم أنا سيث كوفار